did I see you say that evening time heat
exposure increases growth hormone
release by 16 times but subsequent
sessions of the same only increase it by
a very small margin you're absolutely
right if you want to get more resilient
cold exposure is going to be great
anytime post cold exposure your body is
going to heat up think of your body
heating up as waking up so if you are
concerned about not being able to sleep
then I would suggest you do your cold
exposure earlier in the day heat does
the opposite you're going to heat up
while you're in the deliberate heat
exposure but afterwards there's a post
heating dip in temperature people always
say how cold how hot well for heat is
generally between 187 degrees Fahrenheit
and 212 degrees Fahrenheit and for cold
it's cold enough that you really want to
get the hell out but that you can stay
in safely because I don't want anyone to
kill themselves but doing this stuff and
showing that the threshold you're trying
to hit each week is at least you can do
more but at least 11 minutes of
uncomfortable but safe cold exposure per
week total and 57 minutes per week
minimum size that's what they found